it just doesn't like it's really nice
when we can say this and maybe that
applies to you but at large it just
doesn't like women when women get a
promotion at work they're more likely to
divorce their husband when women out
earn their Madness really why I think
that people are crazy I think the world
has gone mad my theory is okay people
who have come up to me now a lot of
people have come up to me and I don't
know but once I asked one of them how
long were you breastfeed for and they
replied saying oh I'll be older and I
realized everyone that lacks big people
they've been breastfed for long and or
their mom or they are they had a big
Auntie or a big mom and they used to
like that sort of feeling so as an older
adult that's what they seek and that's
the truth and it's unfortunately it's a
cycle I don't know if it's also
unfortunate but it is a circle